how sick are you of people asking if
you're natural
god now at this point i'm used to it
because
i've been getting it for like a decade
like but what i've noticed is
a lot of it is really dependent upon the
type of content which i put out so when
i'm doing vlogs
and day-to-day stuff not many people
talk about steroids or anything like
that because the focus is
on something else like just happened in
the video when it peaked
uh recently was when i did uh a full
week of training in ibiza
my current split um and i was at the gym
training topless i managed to get myself
probably one of the best conditions i've
been in for a while
it's not that i was bigger it was just
that i was leaner so obviously when you
get leaner you have the
appearance of looking bigger but because
when i was in the gym
i was topless i was like seriously
pumped up
because my physique trains it changes a
lot from
you know me flattered but pumped up so i
was just like jesus like that looks
pretty damn crazy and then the whole
argument comes
with obviously naturally not natural and
then
a few other big youtubers started making
videos on whether i'm natural
or not derek from more plates more dates
yeah greg doucette
i think gregory said like three videos
of me this summer which is easy views
man
yeah so in a way it's good because i get
some publicity from him
but you know if someone thinks i've
taken something
most of the time they're always going to
think that there's not really much i can
do to change their mind
but the thing that annoys me is when
people message me like oh do you know
you actually think you're such a role
model but now that i know that you're
not natural
i just because of some guys on youtube
because he has a proper cult following
people believed everything he says and
what was his justification for why
you're on gear
because of the supposed low levels of
body fat which i have he said i had six
body fat which is not true no way do i
have six percent why
i would say most of the time hovering
around 10 11
but it's the distribution of where i
hold my body fat i don't have
a huge amount unlike my abs or like my
torso area it's like a lot of is on the
thighs
and lower back but
he definitely eyed that wrong and i
think a lot of people
assume that i hold you know that peak
condition which i was in
they assume i'm like that all the time
but i'm not you know if i
times when i'm not looking my best i
just don't show it i don't like
when i'm looking like a little bit
chubbier for me i'm not going to take a
picture with myself like that
i'm going to find like the lighting
where i look the best and then i'll show
people
that's what people need to understand
like when they see me in
especially instagram if you see pictures
of me topless
that is me when i'm looking my best if
you're in this position if i've been to
the gym
got a pump on or i've found like the
right lighting you know
i'm picking the best picture of like 20
to 30 with a pro photographer
yeah somebody who knows what angle to
get
so there was that um
and does it irritate you does it does it
get to you it does when people say
that i'm a liar and the thing is i've
never made a video
addressing this because i there is no
universal test to prove that someone is
natural
it doesn't exist you there's things you
can do you take like a
the lie detector test you get blood work
done
there's a few other things you can do as
well but it doesn't prove
that you have never ever taken steroids
you know if i'd done all those things
you know and
like okay well maybe you're natural now
but maybe a year ago or for the you know
from the age of 22 to 26 you would
probably take steroids
to build a foundation and now you're not
so
it's annoying i wish that universal test
did exist so you could take it so you
can take it if it would take 100
and i would want everyone to take it
because it would be nice to know
[Music]
who actually is natural and who's not
imagine how much larry wheels would
break that test
i know there's a lot of people that
break that test
i do think there are some athletes out
there who are natural and they look
unbelievable
um there is also a whole lot of people
who
are taking stuff in the fitness industry
it's a very competitive industry and
people are trying to look the very best
people are willing to take or do
whatever it takes do you understand why
people
think that given the sort of condition
that you're in yeah
i think if i was looking at myself
i would definitely think um it's
achievable to get i don't think i'm like
freaky
i think everything's like in proportion
i don't have like crazy delts i don't
have like spots or anything
but this is the thing which is
interesting because i have friends a lot
of friends who have taken stuff
uh you know the guy was used to be in
business with
he was taking quite quite a lot of stuff
and he didn't look very good
like didn't look that impressive there's
a lot of people who are taking gear and
they don't
look that great now let's say for
example i'm one of those people i'm
taking a lot of gear
and i look okay and then i see a
physique like mine
and i'd be like god if this is what i
look like and i'm taking all this
imagine what he's taking they cannot
comprehend
that i'm actually not taking anything at
all
so that's something which i imagine if
anyone who's taking steroids
and they look at my physique and they
don't look anywhere near as good then
they will naturally just assume that i'm
taking something and that'll trade them
yeah um
[Music]
and what i'll i always like to show i'll
send you this picture you may put on
the individual make it make it appear
now there's a picture of me 10 years old
and
like i have very strange development of
like
i've got abs i've got like my calves
i've got biceps
and i'm like look this is me at 10 years
old before pmt
yeah so obviously i'm not a normal
person
like genetics are definitely in my favor
and because this is like my
biggest passions it's my career i've
dedicated my life to it
for the past decade i've been training
for 12 years
then yeah i'm gonna look quite good
one of the things i always find funny
about it is that because we've known
each other for so long
and i still know you as the guy that we
used to spot me in the gym and we used
to train together and do whatever at the
university gym
when training upstairs at the seat
center for sport and excellence in
newcastle uni
um and seeing that trajectory you've got
sort of linearly bigger
pretty much since i've known you so
maybe plateaued a little bit over the
last like sort of four years
conditions maybe improved a little bit
we essentially just got linearly bigger
yeah from when we've known each other
yeah and i appreciate why people on the
internet
who look and see the end result think
that that's ridiculous
but i put up on my ig dean make it
appear
now uh yesterday of us when we were
working for
globe girls doing like hosting heavily
oiled up
very very oiled up yeah very slippery uh
like
that and that's just this sort of slow
and steady way progression
another thing as well i've been mates
with your
ex flatmates your ex-girlfriends
um and also them watched your um
progression i guess into youtube
none of that you would have to have such
an unbelievable conspiracy network to
keep everybody quiet
yeah about what it is that you're on
yeah for no one amongst that
even like an ex-girlfriend is the
patient zero
for the person who would want to call
out the thing that would rumble
their ex and she never did right and
then
the only other thing like if anyone's
got questions and this is what i always
say because people know that i know you
and they say i'm [ __ ] now what's he
on i'm like
he travels to a lot of different
countries how effective at smuggling
like not only is he a youtuber but he's
also like a top level drug runner
like smuggled testosterone and growth
hormone and insulin especially last year
the amount of places i went to last year
like effectively trying to do that would
have been
[Laughter]
so yeah i think when did it get worse
or when was there a period before you're
now quite equanimous and relaxed about
it
was there a period where you think i'm
gonna have to address this
when i started youtube that's when a lot
of the rumors came about
um and i wanted i wanted to address it i
wanted to put a video together but i
i was thinking so many times i thought
how to do this properly
it must be because because i've seen
other people do it and they failed
miserably
i've seen simian panda he tried to make
a video claiming that he was natural
and he got so much hate for it so much
hate what did he do wrong
i think people just don't believe him
they look at his physique and they're
like no
it's not possible that you're natural do
you think he is he could be
i don't know this is the thing i don't
know what all these people are doing
you just assuming and
all these people that make videos about
me it's like you don't know me you don't
know what i do
this is just you make an assumption
based on the way i look
it's what everyone is doing with simi
panda like
he does look he looks crazy he looks
freaky
but he could he could be genetic free
you know billions of people on this
planet there are going to be some
genetic freaks out there
and it's been a while since i've seen
that video but he did a lie detector
test i think he did a few other things
as well
people just straight up refused to
believe it like and if i was to do the
same thing try and make this video do
all these tests
if somebody is in their head convinced
that you
take steroids it's almost impossible to
change their mind that would be an
interesting one so if there's people
watching who think that that would be a
good idea for a video
i'd love to know in the comments what
level of evidence they would accept
yeah to believe like if you were to do a
thing
an independently administered this test
or whatever
because i think you're quite right it's
kind of like
the boy that cried wolf happy to
continue to accuse you
of using pens but also
there is no level of evidence that they
would be happy with to accept that
you're not
yeah and even let's say for example
i was trying to imagine a world where
there actually was a test
then i would imagine people would pay
could possibly pay huge amounts of money
to cheat the test because that would
have a huge impact on their career
and then maybe how many programs they
sell so
i i just i can never i honestly wish
they'd never been invented i wish there
was didn't
exist because you wouldn't have because
and then everyone else would be and
there wouldn't be all this [ __ ] and all
this like
pointless debates i used to to argue
with people i used to get into arguments
with people online
and try and prove you know the comments
like no no i'm not sure it
just a huge waste of energy i spent all
day every day arguing with people as to
whether i'm breathing
on youtube yeah on youtube on instagram
whatever it might be and i'm like
it's not productive whatsoever can't
change the mind
waste time have you ever intended to
take steroids
um i've been curious to know what i
would look like but i think i would just
look
freaky like too big i don't want to be
that big like i'm actually
i've been very content with the way i
have looked and my progression
and i think now like you know it's kind
of plateaued i've kind of looked the
same for the past
few years if i wanted to take my
condition to the next level
what would have to happen is i'd have to
live a very monk life
existence the social life would take a
hit everything would need to be very
regimented i probably need to have a
coach
every session would need to be so
unbelievably brutal
my nutrition would have to be on point
every meal prepped no alcohol no
parties eight hours sleep every single
night
and yeah that would look better i
probably put on a bit size
but that's not a life i won't live it's
a price you're not prepared to pay yeah
i compete twice before
and did you yeah 2014 2015 wbff
okay and it was a good experience to
to actually go on stage and to go
through the whole process of competing
i didn't like it was the first time in
my life where i was like really not
happy with my physique
because i was just like oh god like i'm
just not leaning even though i was
[ __ ] shredded i was like
oh you can't see like the striations in
my ass
like who the hell cares about that but
that was like
the weird mindset that i was getting
into
are you concerned about having a
physique like yours and putting it out
online
about what sort of body dysmorphia that
might cause downstream
for me for other people for other people
uh
yeah because i think
there's a lot of people who would want
to look like me
and it's i don't want to be like
brutal but i want to be realistic with
people
i think anyone should go out there with
a mindset of trying to achieve
their dreams and not letting anything
stop them
but if someone is like you know
they've got like kids work in like a
really
stressful job and they have at the end
of the day
really [ __ ] genetics like they're gonna
have a very very hard time
coming close to looking like me when my
whole life is dedicated to looking like
this and i've got good genetics as well
so it's tough and that's why i've never
ever seen my videos you can look like me
i've never said that once
most of my videos have been put out
there to just
help people to stop making mistakes
which i've made like to just help them
eat
better eat the right things and to just
more importantly just
lift good proper technique technique is
massive
form execution intensity
most people lack that when they go to
the gym
so if everyone's focused on that a
little bit more they would be
a hell of a lot closer to looking the
way they want to look or the best that
they could possibly look
i think that's a good insight that when
people do the comparison game
we're not all starting from the same
base point yeah like
i i'm as much of a like [ __ ] talker and
a critic
as will be but i believe that you're
natural
and given that fact and given the way
that we've
both seen friends of ours mutual
acquaintances
jump on huge cycles and then come off
and not make
that much difference to their physique
you have to think like
there's something in you i know that
your passion is lifting weights
there's something in your particular
physiology
composition that doesn't actually want
you to be that big or that lame
yeah and the fact that that's that can
be true
means that sadly some people's passions
aren't actually what they're going to be
good at
you can love lifting weights but if your
love of lifting weights is determined by
the outcome
ie and goal physique that you get at the
end of it some people
are putting themselves into a situation
where the only outcome
is disappointment yeah things like that
should still feel the smaller
yeah it's funny because a lot of people
say oh you should do what you're really
passionate about
but sometimes you should just do what
you're really good at
[Music]